In nearly every corner of the earth. And so wage war against each other,
their weapons are what nature gave them. Some have strong armor,
deadly stingers or sharp mandibles.
And then there's this tiny and not very impressive ant,
but it rules the biggest empire.
Any aunt has ever built a cottony spanning continents and fighting
Wars that leave millions of casualties.
Let's take a look at this unlikely warrior S then epitomized Humanae,
the Argentina hat.
This story begins in the floodplains around the paranoia river in South America.
It's a crowded and megalopolis where dozens of ant species fight for
dominance, including fire ants, army ants,
and that rather unimpressive Argentina at it measures only two to three
millimeters in length. And with its small mandibles,
it's surprising that it's survived among its buff competitors.
That homes are equally unremarkable their colonies range from fairly small to
very large and could be found anywhere under logs in loose leaf litter
or the former colonies of other ads here.
Argentina ants prepare their most effective weapon against their competitors.
Bodies.
Most ant species have only one queen to produce ants while Argentine
ants went all in on numbers for every 120 workers.
There's one queen laying up to 60 eggs a day.
So that is grow fast and have millions or billions of
individuals,
teams of Queens and workers frequently branch out and found new colonies.
But their strategy has a downside as colonies grow and produce a lot of
offspring mutations occur and new colonies adapt to new environments that
DNA slowly changes from generation to generation and differences accumulator.
So after awhile,
the ants that left the colony will become more like a distant cousins and start
to compete with their mother economy and their native South American range.
This is how Argentine ants behave within that colonies.
They are very co-operative and well-organized,
but they fight vicious Wars against other Argentine and colonies and other and
species with equally strong opponents. On every side,
the Argentine ants became extremely aggressive fighting for every inch of
ground, but it could never dominate its neighbors until humans showed up.
We did what humans do and transported things around the world by ship on one of
them, a few Argentina and Queens hitched,
a rider's stowaways from South America to Madeira and new Orleans.
The Argentina suddenly found themselves in a strange world.
Instead of being surrounded by deadly enemies, they found only victims.
Nobody could find them effectively because only a few Argentina and
Queens were introduced to the outside world.
The resulting colonies had very low genetic diversity on top of that,
the introduced Argentine ants can up to 90% of their Queens every year,
fewer Queens, less genetic variation.
So as these colonies spread across the landscape,
aunts that left the colony were no longer considered distant cousins as a
result, the new colonies form, not opposing,
but cooperating parties called super colonies.
This is a very uncommon strategy in the United Kingdom.
Only a few of the 16,000 ant species have evolved super colonies.
A super colony was established on the West coast of the USA and became a base
for the tiny ants global conquest today,
the Argentine and inhabits the Mediterranean zones of six continents and many
islands.
This one super colony was especially successful establishing sister locations in
California, Europe, Japan,
New Zealand and Australia forming one massive Intercontinental mega colony
of Argentine ends. This makes them the largest society on earth,
more numerous than even the human one, but their success has changed.
The ecosystems they invaded.
California is a perfect example of this in that greed for more territory,
the invading Argentine ants have overrun and replaced 90% of the native
and species, including several species of California in the carpenter ants.
Although carpenter and workers are giants.
Their colonies have only between 3000 and 6,000 individuals and stand no
chance against an expanding super colony of billions of Argentineans
Argentine ant workers attack by wiping toxic chemicals on their victims,
which irritates the enemy and marks them as a target for other Argentine ads.
When they attack the Argentine ants wash over their victims,
clinging onto their opponents in groups and pulling apart their lives.
It doesn't matter how many of them die. There are always more.
Once the colony is overrun and exterminated,
the Argentine ants feed them that victims bruise and take over their home and
territory.
The tiny ants numbers allow them to hunt down and devour such an excessive,
massive,
different insects that over time some species do as a peer from the ants
territory,
completely Argentine ants don't care about working with the local flora and
fauna. They consume them and move on.
And if their next job happens to be human property,
they will rudely make themselves at home there too.
They forage in dumpsters bowls of pet food and sneak into kitchens to claim
leftovers, not just our homes,
our gardens and fields are also acted by, by finance.
Since they tend to hoards of aphids as their cattle,
the aphids feed from plants and produce a sweet honeydew,
which they trade with the ants for protection.
Since the ants have no major enemy to fair in their new homes,
the aphids thrive and ultimately kill the plants they live on.
So on top of being a major disruption for the ecosystems, they invade,
they are also a huge past for agriculture,
but the rule of the Argentina is being challenged.
Parts of the super colonies have broken off and become their own empires.
A merciless civil war has broken out. For example,
the Lake Hodges super colony has been fighting against the very large colony for
years in San Diego County. A massive war is going on over eight dynamic,
frontline stretching over kilometers,
an estimated 30 million ants die here each year on other fronts,
an old acquaintance from the Paranal river has risen from the shadows red
imported fire ants,
which were accidentally introduced from their old home to the coast of Alabama.
Not only other red fire ants, fierce fighters,
and more than able to deal with the Argentine.
And they are also able to form super colonies themselves.
Now the old Wars from their distant home have been taken to a foreign
battleground in the Southeastern us,
the super colonies clashed fiercely the Argentina found themselves
outgunned by the fire ants.
The fire ants major workers are more than twice the size of the Argentines and
wield venom injecting stairs.
Even though the Argentine ands fought fiercely the firearms were too much for
them after countless lost battles, the red imported fire and exterminated,
the Argentine ants super colony from much of the Southeastern us.
This is one territory lost,
but the Argentine ants will fight on this amazing network of cooperating.
Super colonies is the biggest success in their history.
And they'll not give it up because of a small.
Defeat. They will stand their.
Ground against any enemy that might arise.
No matter if it's on the paranoia river or on one of the large battlefields
across the world.
These videos were developed with the support of curiosity stream,
a subscription streaming service with thousands of documentaries and non-fiction
titles courts. Cause out viewers can visit
curiositystream.com/ [inaudible] to get a free 31 day trial to watch films like
big world in his little garden,
a documentary that takes a close look at the world of insects around us or other
documentaries by the likes of Stephen Hawking, David Katzenberg,
and many more all available for offline viewing.
Once your trial is over the subscription is only $2 99 a month.
Curiosity stream was founded by the same people who started the discovery
channel with documentary Spanish signs, nature, history, technology,
and lifestyle.
It's a great way to binge watch fun videos while accidentally things.
Thank you so much to our friends at CuriosityStream for supporting our aunts
obsession and making ambitious projects like this possible.
Stay tuned for part three and visit curiosity,
stream.com/coats cause ours feel free trial.
[Inaudible].